gal gadot mary j blige and the stars at
the Palm Springs International Film
Festival Plus Yara Shahidi is grown ish
and we're on the set of her spin-off oh
[Music]
my god I missed you guys
hello is the first daily daddy of 2018
and I hope your years off to a good
start
mine is off to a running start I
literally went from sweats to a suit to
cover the opening gala at the Palm
Springs International Film Festival
which is why we didn't have a video for
you guys yesterday I'm sorry right now
the Palm Springs festival always is the
first red carpet of the year and brings
out huge stars to the desert Wonder
Woman gal gadot mary j blige and Allison
Janney were among the Nights honorees
but there's one name you need to know
this award season Timothy Shalem a he's
the young star who literally took my
breath away and call me by your name and
as I found out last night this kid is
freaking charming call me by your name
because I'm still trying to get the
pronunciation core yes Timothy Timothy
anything I Shalem a right show them it's
supposed to be Timothy but that just
seems like a lot yeah that's a lot to
ask people and I don't want to be
totally unrelated it's a lot to ask
people only because I think we're gonna
be hearing your name a lot this award
season Timothy sha'lame please don't be
awkward it's it's great to get to be
here to support to me and to get to go
through the whole thing with him and to
to watch it happen through his eyes it's
right the special thanks to Army's wife
Elizabeth chambers who's here tonight as
well who was as crucial this process as
anyone and who let me crawl all over her
husband for two months so thank you for
that not only are you getting attention
for your work and call me by your name
but also your rapping skills
have you given up on your future rapping
I'm retired I'm calling it right now
Timothy is gonna steal some hearts and
hopefully that Oscar all right let's
move on to another rising star miss Yara
Shahidi her character Zoe from black-ish
is heading off to college and her own
spin-off grown ish which premieres
tonight it's a bit of art imitating life
with a 17-year old as et's the shell
turner found out when she stopped by the
set this is yours your own show on
blackish yarr plays the eldest child of
Tracee Ellis Ross and Anthony Anderson
who has a hard time when she moves out
you know my baby's off to college yeah I
don't know what parents doesn't take it
hard
Yara was going through her real life
college application process and she was
offered her own spin-off it was kind of
scary moving on to this other adventure
of like I've been on this show for
almost four years and now I'm across the
line it feels like miles away she was
accepted to Harvard but she's putting
that on hold while on groan --is-- zoey
is attending a university close to home
she's never been awkward before no she's
never the awkward one she's never been
like thrown you're gonna be awkward as a
freshman in college yes always doing
what huh why dad three days show of a
man if the premise sounds familiar
back in the 80s The Cosby Show sent Lisa
Bonet off to college for her own
spin-off called a different world I
never see Plus a big bad seed bus
tonight 30 years later Yara is looking
to make some TV history of her own love
my cast here and there so amazing so
that's now the cows includes Selena
Gomez's best de francia raisa and
musical prodigies Chloe and Halle who
are also poised for a very big year
because not only are they on groaning
but they will make their first
appearance at Coachella the full lineup
was released yesterday literally while I
was interviewing folks in Palm Springs
so I'm just now catching up and it is
epic the weekend Beyonce and Eminem will
headline the three-day festival which
takes place
over two weekends in the desert now we
all knew Beyonce would be there she of
course is making good after having to
bow out from last year's festival
because she was pregnant now I should
know me I've been waiting for this for a
year to the date here's my reaction when
I first learned she was headlining a
year ago take a week off Danny how are
you feeling right now no new year save
me folks sorry I still feel that way to
be honest um Wow but there's also some
other awesome artists performing I want
you guys to hit me up on Twitter or the
comments section and let me know who
you're most excited to see and what we
can are you going come find me weekend -
all right I might go book all right
that's enough for me you guys thanks so
much for watching we'll be back tomorrow
with another dose of daily Jenny so be
sure to hit subscribe I really I'm so
happy to be back you guys thanks for
watching